the Royals rarely talk about their love
lives but Prince Harry just confirmed
that he is dating American actress Megan
Markel gay he broke the news in order to
slam the press he is royally upset about
the way his girlfriend is being treated
calling it abuse the private life has to
has to be private
Prince Harry was adamant he wants the
press to back off Harry defended his new
girlfriend American actress Megan Marvel
in this statement that was released
today by Kensington Palace in it the 32
year old condemned the media for quote
abuse and harassment it has been a
tsunami of interest in her life her
family and the media have left no stone
unturned and that is what is at the root
of this unprecedented and utterly
extraordinary statement it also mentions
quote the nightly legal battles to keep
defamatory stories out of papers and her
mother having to struggle past
photographers in order to get to her
front door Harry also takes issue with
what he calls the quote racial
undertones of press coverage Megan's
father is white
her mother is african-american and she
has described herself as biracial
meanwhile there are new development et
has learned that megan has replaced her
u.s. PR firm with a british legal team
the actresses also filed a complaint
with the British Press Complaints
Commission
she has complained about theis the level
of harassment and abuse that her family
have been exposed to and she's made it
very clear that she will not at any
stage be speaking about her relationship
with Prince Harry of course who can
blame Harry for wanting to protect Megan
it's important to remember just how much
his mother Princess Diana was hounded by
the paparazzi during her lifetime the
Prince of course grew up in the
spotlight and last year he told Sky News
about wanting to share it with a partner
you